foreign
[Music]
foot long plant eater
despite years of research
still trying to understand
why it had this bizarre shaped head
[Music]
oh
the most distinctive feature about the
Paco stores of course is this really
weird Dome that they have on their heads
all around it is a series of very odd
tubercles and knobbles and Bubbles they
look quite dragon-like
when they first saw these very thick
Dome skulls and each domes could be up
to 30 centimeters in thickness they were
thought to be very strong it was thought
that maybe they were using them for
headbutting each other in contests over
social hierarchy
today animals like bighorn sheep butt
heads in this way
skull helps protect their brain from
Impact
but does this fully explain
pachycephalosaur's domed head
a number of paleontologists thought they
should look inside the skulls
they sliced up a number of
pachycephalosaur Domes and when they did
that they found out that maybe it wasn't
strong enough to withstand these direct
head-on impacts
however they did discover something else
suggesting the Dome had a different use
surface was marked with a mesh of tiny
fibers
perhaps they supported brightly colored
skin used to attract the mates
new Theory
theater two
thousand and thirteen when a new
discovery was made
a Pakistan for the soul was found with
marks showing it had survived multiple
injuries to the top of its head
and it wasn't a one-off
they went back and looked through
Historic Museum Collections and
discovered that actually there was quite
a lot of evidence for these lesions in a
similar place across a whole bunch of
different pachycephalosaurs
this is good evidence that they probably
were head-butting
so were the skulls strong enough to
protect pachycephalosaur's brain after
all
scanning technology
we can use CT scans to build virtual
models of the bones and then we can
subject those to various engineering
tests in the same way that we do with an
airplane part or an artificial hip
this provided the final piece of
evidence
well domes could actually have withstood
an enormous amount of force
the sort of force that goes through
American footballers when they hit each
other
[Music]
we now believe
pachycephalosaurs used their head both
as a formidable weapon
and as a colorful display
two ways to demonstrate who was boss in
their prehistoric world
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]